speaking of editing so we live in a
world that sort of fetishizes brevity
and short things and what do you see is
the virtue of continuing to write very
long works in that world and how do you
negotiate that editorially well I do not
share this Federation of brevity I am
I'm in the anti brevity camp my stories
have actually throughout my career if I
look back I've been getting longer and
longer as I said when I began in the 70s
I wrote mostly short stories and then at
a certain point my short stories were
getting longer they were now novelettes
and then when I won my first Hugo was
for a novella so each of these is a
longer category in the other and then
eventually six seven years into my
career I started writing novels but they
were relatively short novels and at some
point along the way I for my sins I
found myself writing Game of Thrones and
it just kept getting longer and longer
and longer but I liked it I think it's
it the length gives it a it gives it a
richness gives it a texture you can
create world building you can create an
immersive world and immersive universe
that the readers will lose themselves in
for for the length of the novel and
perhaps for many novels beyond that when
he many works and I like that there was
there was a yesterday when we attended
the awards ceremony the they were
flashing quotations about writing on the
walls of the of the site where the
awards were being presented and one of
them was a quote that I wrote for a book
hold on fantasy it was about when I die
they can keep their heaven I'd rather go
to middle-earth and token was the first
really great world builder he created
middle-earth and in such detail that it
seems like a real place to me I mean I I
know middle-earth much more than I know
many real places
you know I what do I know about Uruguay
I know a lot more about Middle Earth
than I do about Uruguay I can describe
its scenic wonders and the different
customs of its people and you know the
roads that go from there there and and
some of the Kings who have ruled over it
and past ages and the languages and the
geography it's an amazing place and I've
tried to do the same with same with
Westeros that's one of the things that I
think is important about writing fantasy
epic fantasy there are many different
types of fantasy of course is if any of
you are aspiring writers or ever took
fiction courses or studied fiction in
high school or college or something like
that they used to at least in my day
talk about the elements of fiction you
know plot theme character etc etc and
one of the elements of fiction was
setting but in most mainstream fiction
contemporary fiction setting gets short
shrift it's okay it's in Chicago and
okay it's in New York City it's or even
it's in Victorian England we know all
about that
but the greatest fantasy to my mind is
distinguished by its settings the
setting becomes almost a character
middle-earth becomes a real place and
becomes a character the Shire
Rivendell ministereth Mordor each of
these is very vivid and real and I tried
to do the same with with my own Westeros
create a setting that was almost a
character in its own right did you
notice that one of those quotations on
the wall was said by you but was
attributed to me I did notice that hey I
thought that was very strange question
if said exactly the same I complained to
someone but no change was made I'm glad
you noticed that I thought it was very
bizarre there was also a typo in one of
my other yes because be a cause well you
found a different typo
and you know there was one where I said
you know that because I'm a reader I
have lived a thousand lives and loved a
thousand loves but they changed the
loves to live so as I've lived a
thousand lives and loved a thousand
lives which repetitious different we had
a lovely time we're very grateful was
that wonderful event
wonderful event um the awards were
handsome and very nice we got to meet
the mayor yes and there were 80 82
authors on stage and amazing authors I
wish all their books had been on sale
yeah that would have gone home with big
stack of them